seeing the entire series I want to say
congrats I'm not going to do any
spoilers just congrats thanks you know
um Milling questions but I like throwing
a curve at the beginning okay uh if some
you've done a lot of stuff if someone
has actually never seen anything you've
done before what is the first thing
you'd like them watching and why uh
comment because it's a movie where I met
my husband and fell in love okay yeah I
can't uh that's kind of the perfect
answer thanks that was the first one
that came to mind so uh listen what was
it about this project that said oh I I
have to do this anytime something
terrifies me and I don't know if I can
pull it off I kind of run towards it
which is probably something I should
look at
um I thought the opportunity to play
this character over uh the span of 10
years change so drastically from being a
very young 25 year old single mom
bartender nurse a caretaker in every way
who's really trying her best but
ultimately the family secrets and the
ways in which she tries to survive what
she refers to in a later episode as the
world is a cruel place
um ultimately those decisions uh end up
kind of shattering the bond with her son
that is the most important in her life
and
it's kind of a Shakespearean level
tragedy
um I was quite moved by the idea of and
challenge of playing uh an imperfect
mother
um
especially as a young mom of now too
um I I think it brings up a lot how is
it for you look do you enjoy playing a
character who is doing things that you
probably like really disagree with
um is it like more fun is it more
challenging like what is it like getting
in that headspace I think that
the joy of playing pretend is getting to
experiment and live through sometimes
the things that we fear the most
um I think
the ways in which these characters as
mother and son
are able to survive the the idea that
they're both living in these deep states
of denial
um which is either a learned or
inherited trait
um it was fascinating to me I think
there is kind of a catharsis in getting
to explore parts of yourself that are
scary through the safe parameters of a
story where you know how it starts and
you know how it ends I have always found
um
that there is some kind of emotional
truth that you'll learn about yourself
um through acting out other people's
lives and I don't know there's something
um I just really enjoy this job sure
um when are you able now like how much
can you when you're playing a character
like this how much at the end of the day
can you shut it off go back to who you
are and then like or and how much are
you sort of like leaving a piece close
to the surface so you can just inhabit
as soon as you can step back on set
you know I've I've
lived here's whose emotions are quite
explosive and who leave a lot on the
field and with this character there is
so much
um
kind of violence and Trauma around her
and there's quite of like an implosion
into herself kind of like almost like a
self-violence that happens
I had a lot of anxiety uh while shooting
this show leading up to uh some of the
more challenging scenes
um so by the time that we got to
shooting them
um I was fully armed with having worked
with a social worker and a psychologist
to inform me and and spoken with a woman
who had had a similar life experience I
felt like I really wanted to bring
empathy and do these moments Justice and
so by the time I finished the scene I
was so relieved that that experience was
over that I was just glad to go home and
like you know watch Top Chef to be
perfectly honest sure completely
um one listen uh you have some great
scenes with Tom and I'm not going to get
into any of the specifics but obviously
he really gave himself to this role and
just went for it uh what is it like and
I know it's a little generic but what is
it like working with a scene partner who
was clearly giving his all to the role I
think it's motorific to have an actor
who is also your producer who's in it
with you to have actors like Tom and
Amanda who are so incredibly unafraid to
go to those depths and to explore that
Darkness
um especially under the guidance of
terrific Direction like Cornell
mondrusco it was just a joy and I
remember after a particularly
challenging scene
Tom just came over and kind of threw his
arms around me and we just kind of stood
silently hugging each other
um I think that connection is so lovely
especially
when you've really lived through these
real moments emotionally as characters
who are so disconnected and who are who
are so desperate to connect to each
other but are kind of afraid of and for
each other uh it's really nice to have a
scene partner that is in it with you I'm
so curious how have you been describing
this series to friends and family
without giving things away
um
I would say the crowded room is a
psychological Thriller
um
that unfolds through a series of
interviews with Amanda seyfried's
character as she is tasked with
uncovering the mysterious past of a
young man played by Tom Holland who is
arrested after a shooting in 1979 and as
the mystery unfolds we learn more and
more and about his childhood and his
past and what might have led to this
crime that was very good thanks
one of the things that like is this
you're not in this scene but I just want
to talk about it real quick I was so
blown away by the scale of what they did
in New York City outside Radio City and
just shooting in New York City and
recreating it was like movie level
except it's a TV show yes you know yeah
I I
you know the show opens with this kind
of catalyst event this shooting in in
Rockefeller Center in 1979 and
um I think that there's a lot to be said
about
um violence and I think the importance
of depicting violence and
um survival from violence is incredibly
important
um and I also am very
um happy and proud that our crew did it
in a responsible way with not real guns
uh green plastic ones that got replaced
in post I think the importance of safety
uh emotionally and otherwise on set is
uh Paramount couldn't agree more on that
note I have to stop I'm just going to
say congrats thank you and wish you
nothing but the best thank you thank you
for giving me your time thank you